Thanks pleasure to be here and thanks
Michael you were he was a star even when
he was a freshman graduate student at
MIT and I I do remember that talk which
was yeah it was a joy to give that one
it was HC I was was actually hot at MIT
then which wasn't true were the first
couple times I gave talks at MIT so it's
it's came along came a long way there
and I think Michaels part of the reason
why and if you can't hear me please let
me know am i speaking loudly enough okay
great so teaching us coaching and
learning at scale I'm very passionate
about this topic I think most of us who
are professors who teach spent a lot of
our time teaching think a lot about how
we teach and so oh thank you so much so
one thing what I want to do is I want to
put my money where my mouth is and with
and make this into a lecture make this
into one of my class session so i'm
going to set with a question okay what's
the best way to present this data
audience participation here's some data
I don't even saying what it's about
what's the best way to present it how
should it be presented all right think
to yourself the answer and it's a little
bit hard to answer that in a setting
like this so but i'm going to reword the
question a little bit and make it a
little bit easier to answer which of the
following visualizations is the most
effective for presenting this data is it
one this one or two this one how many
people think number one is the best how
many people think number two is the best
okay everybody's voting for number two
pretty much and for those of you who
study visualization there's a lot of
reasons as visual principles area isn't
best represented this way it's
misleading color is not used in a way
that that's helpful to allow you to make
the comparisons length is a better way
to show quantitative differences and so
on and so forth this is a very easy one
all right if we know anything about
visual principles let's try another one
what's the best way to describe or
visualize this data okay and that's only
a very small fraction of it it's going
to be a little harder to answer that one
don't shout out your answer
yet let me reword the question again
which of these visualizations is the
most effective for this data okay that
that or that of course you can't even
really see the numbers this is jeopardy
this is data data from the show Jeopardy
and it's about which questions which
categories of questions are used and how
much money people have made from the
different categories and so on does
anyone feel that they know definitively
which one might be best most effective
well for what actually haven't said what
for and that's another issue but imagine
you're a professor who needs to give
feedback to students on this very high
dimensional problem visualizing data
this high dimension if you're like me
it's not actually super straightforward
to do you might have some views but you
might not be absolutely certain you're
going to give the right feedback about
these maybe you will know that that's
not so great because of various reasons
we can talk about which I don't have
time to talk about but these two they're
pros and cons is kind of difficult so
keep that in mind as I go on so what I
want to talk about is sort of 22
different topics that I feel are related
one is learning its scale we see with
MOOCs and so on people putting a courses
online and having many many people learn
together or not together but learning at
once and this idea i'm calling teaching
is coaching which is how i now think
about teaching which is rather than we
give you material gets to deteriorate
ested and they got it right or not they
better study and get it right I thinking
more like the sports metaphor where a
coach has practice and and they are
alongside the athlete and they have them
practice and they fail soft and safe and
they repeat and so on and maybe you know
the the exam is the big game or
something like that but the coach is on
your side and you just repeat and fail
fast it's more like that and let's try
trying to teach my class which class is
now which is sort of a different talk
but but what I am kind of thinking about
is these two are kind of related
they're there I'm thinking about the to
inter inter woven and we can think about
two different things at least I am what
is pedagogy that interlinks these two
and in particular mastery learning and
structured peer learning I'll talk about
both of these and the other is tools so
technical tools that we can develop to
that are motivated by these pedagogy
pedagogy is the science of teaching and
so and in particular automated feedback
peer feedback and online discussions and
so let me talk about these briefly so
mastery learning I got a little bike
here because some in contacts about the
Swiss cheese model of learning whether
you kind of fall through the holes which
is when you're you know traditional
teaching environments you study math
topic you maybe get to see on the test
and you move on and see on test means
you didn't actually learn it properly
and yet you're supposed to go on to
something that builds on what you had
before so it's kind of like learning to
ride a bike where you didn't master the
balance part but now you're going on to
pedaling you know it just doesn't work
so a lot of the thinking now is that you
know mastery learning requires practice
and if you want to do practice you need
feedback to know if you got the
questions right or not at least for it's
safer math and there's a lot of really
interesting automation we're going on
with automated feedback automated tools
for feedback say you with math problems
it I will not be talking about that
today but that's kind of one way to go
is with fully automated feedback tools
and modeling online what people are
doing and personalizing say the feedback
automatically so that's really exciting
area learning a scale that I won't be
talking about but there's another issue
which is for more qualitative work that
students are doing and so another trend
is to have peer feedback when you have a
lot of students you can't have one
instructor or a few instructors give
them all feedback and furthermore
there's a lot of benefits to peers
giving feedback to each other which
we'll talk about and this is especially
important for a qualitative work like
writing essays or design like HCI or
information visualization
where there's judgment calls potentially
so peer assessment and design courses
the state of the artists work that's
been done here at Stanford well sort of
Stanford and San Diego and CMU and
expensive how you count but kind of all
around about co carne at all the key
ideas here so they've been looking at
HCI courses in particular although it's
been used in other courses too and that
the trick is to have students have a
rubric which is basically just a table
saying here is what you need to look at
when you are assessing say this design
you train the students on other examples
of that rubric you say look at how
here's a design look at how the
instructors graded this design of the
past or gave feedback on it in the past
now you give feedback on a design and
then oh well you were off you know you
didn't just you didn't grade it sort of
the same way as previous instructors
said you should so why don't you adjust
and that's that's working pretty well
it's getting students and this is an
example rubric where you have like a
category then here are like the
different scores you can give it
unsatisfactory bare minimum satisfactory
above beyond and you sort of train the
students and do how to do this rubric
for each assignment and then you have
some peer assessment so so this is
working pretty well but there are a
bunch of issues and there's a lot of
really interesting research going on
around this so kulkarni at all you know
notice various things like students
sometimes feel like they put in more
effort than the other students this is a
common thing that that we see with you
know things generally in classrooms
there's issues with transparency so
Renee who's sitting here is a new paper
about that that if maybe if if they're
not sure how the grating is being done
and they have some questions but if you
show them too much about it we've all
seen this if professors have tried to
show how they graded exams to students
because the students think the grading
wasn't fair and then the students are
even more unhappy this is sort of a
well-known result there's difference
with different differences in how
difficult a TA is on the grading and
then the students get upset there's good
to work on and grading the greater like
what's grade the students to see how
good a graders they are there's issues
that with negative reviews they
get low ratings and people generally
these days react negatively to negative
feedbacks there's a lot of issues that
come with this peer assessment so so we
did a little work recently to think
about how can we improve peer assessment
say in the design space or that's how
the result came out anyhow and so the
idea actually is to trade off two
different approaches and I'm saying it's
kind of like ensemble learning in
machine learning so let me talk about
that now so first have to give a quick
review of heuristic evaluation and since
this is PCD seminar think most of you
probably know what it is but maybe not
all of you this is a very standard
approach to assessing designs user
interfaces basically you have a set of
experts with a set of guidelines go
through the guidelines review a design
and say how many errors there are how
many problems that are with a design or
how good the design is and then you
aggregate their results this is very
widely used in practice in user
interface design developed by Nielsen
and mullick in 1990 and so here are some
heuristic guidelines for visualization
that from a report by Steven few like do
not use chart junk do not you do use oh
do not use color shape and so on
arbitrarily do use length and position
properly to show quantitative variable
values do not deceive etc etc and so if
we look at our beautiful graph from
before we can look at and say for
example which guidelines apply or which
ones are violated by this chart and for
example do not use color arbitrarily
although I guess it's the colors of the
flags use length and position for
quantity that is violated and highlight
salient information is violated here etc
all right so what's the standard
alternative to heuristic evaluation that
is used in the literature there's very
there's other things but but kind of the
main alternative is usability studies
have people actually try to or use the
design and so you can do have a whole
big system built and do study on it and
one of my favorites for search
visualizations or search interfaces is
this very old one by writer at all where
they compared bars tile bars and a
scatterplot to kind of just a sort of a
list view and you know found that the
list view is basically the best except
for tile bar it's the second best so I
cuz one reason I like to review the
study because the towel bars is my thing
but the effectiveness the table is best
it's really hard to make visualizations
work for text and search which is why we
don't have them but you know very
careful study done by the people who
didn't develop the design which is
really the best way to do these things
but there's also been studies on
visualizations themselves and so there
was his paper in tokai 2014 by yang at
all where they were like let's just do
pairwise comparisons or studies of like
bar charts and line charts and stacked
bar charts so all they did was a whole
bunch of comparisons of how do you group
these pairs together and it was this
enormous amount of work because they
want to see which ones to use for which
kinds of questions and what kind of
questions that people ask with these
different types like and they turned out
like they asked about extrema and they
did comparisons for correlations but it
was a huge amount of work just to look
at these pairs let's think back at the
example I showed you with the Jeopardy
data those were not just like a couple
of lines those were very complicated
designs so they did get some scores for
a few pairs for a few question types but
we don't have user tested data for
really complicated combinations of
designs so it's going to be really hard
for say a professor who's trying to get
feedback to students to sort of
definitively state which ones are you
know correct or right and so on so
there's also been work on crowd using
crowds workers to do usability tests so
I you know we have this tie
paper due canticle to her extreme of
square pie charts by Sarah where they
did this at that so there's been working
out so by here and and his co-author on
replicating some perception studies
using crowd workers and turns out these
square fide charts are better than pie
charts and donut charts for looking at
proportions so those that's how you can
you can do sort of these usability
studies alright so so I thought well
okay people are using proud workers to
do these little usability tests why
don't I use this in my class I could
make use of the crowd to help assess my
students work and I was inspired by this
work by Dow at all uh also sort of stun
here and elsewhere so the idea was
students should radically iterate on
their designs they should work in teams
this is from the Dow a tile work and
then you can assess the results what
they did was they had people make you
eyes and post the results on google
adwords and that was very clever i'm
like wow an objective assessment that's
great the only problem was it was
adwords it's like click on an ad and to
me that's not really I usability gold so
much that's like a selling goal so it's
not perfect exactly what I want so what
I did the last two years was I had
neutral parties the crowd workers answer
questions about the underlying data in
the visualization so I got a data set
and I had the students make a
visualization about the data set so I
gave him data set I made up a set of
questions I put their designs on the
crowdsourcing platform and we saw how
many questions the people about right
and the theory being if they got more
questions right it was a better design
and I also had the students first design
individually and then I paired them up
in teams that had them iterate on their
designs and have a team submission okay
so we got pretty consistent results it
was great it's great exercise but then I
wanted to think well why don't I do this
with peers instead of crowd workers the
students should answer each other's
questions although you can't have
with that is you once you've answered
questions about a data set you know the
answer so you can't repeat so you have
to have more students and then I also is
like well how does this compare to your
wrist evaluation which is sort of a
standard technique it's a standard
technique and user interface design it
turns out it's not that standard in in
focus least in my experience and in
focus glasses and you think about that
you should I don't think it's really
used that much and improve his and
there's I have some sites to back that
up so my question was what which is more
accurate which is more helpful I was
kind of thinking the question answering
might be so I did a study this summer I
had 47 undergraduate HCI students we had
a have a lecture and some exercises with
infovis and a within participants design
where there were two conditions hg
here's the evaluation or question
answering six was six different data
sets three designs each and attempted to
have them be of low medium and high
quality I made the data so made the
designs and that was the hope so as a
set up with me there was a question
there was a data set with a question
there were three designs and then the
students assess them they either
answered questions about the designs or
they did a heuristic evaluation on the
designs and we did this for multiple
datasets it so in the heuristic
evaluation condition I had this really
had them do only positive heuristics to
keep the scale yes like in some times
before was I in heuristic in one dataset
and over yeah you would only do here is
to can one day to set in question
another so that you couldn't Yeah Yeah
right yes hmm and then all these are on
you're only talking about static
visualisations not interactive arms yes
okay you've been a simple yes why do you
expect heuristic evaluation to be better
than avocat your lessons
you better nose into anyways well I
wasn't right it turns out so um does it
matter because I was wrong and an i had
a bias I thought that this objective
answering the questions would reveal the
true underlying Marid because he because
in we had never done here a stick
evaluation in infovis which I'm now
going to do because of the results of my
study right and so I you know there's
this question about why you the task is
to extract the data from the
visualization yeah right that's what you
want the viewers to be able to do yeah
so why should sure somebody finish the
let me finish the because I'll have some
more reflection on that okay let me get
a few more slides and then let's let's
talk about that did you want to let's do
a couple more slides and then let's talk
about it okay so so the heuristics I had
them do three here by the way i should
say these are these are undergraduates
brand new to HCI in a six-week summer
school course and then we had the one
segment on infovis that i taught so and
the here's I had them only do positive
heuristic so they wouldn't get confused
between positive and negative and so
they would rate 125 the visuals age the
information the visualization is
visually salient the components are used
appropriately and it has a visualization
and successfully presents multiple
relevant facts into a single visual
pattern and then on the question side
each dataset had a different set of
three questions depending on the
underlying data so for example for the
Jeopardy data you would have which year
on average was the most lucrative for
players in terms of earnings based on
these numbers which category would be
the strategically best to select as a
contestant in the game and so on and
there were three choices and only one
was correct so the new idea is to
compare assessments on a measure scale
so this is the new thing that we did so
the procedure is the following we create
measures for the h ii and the
for the heuristic value should and the
question answer answering approach we
compute the correlation between the two
and we assess the reliability so this is
the new thing so that for the HD the
composite rating per participant was to
average the three 'he scores and the QA
the composite rating was this the number
correct averaged so that's the new thing
and then when we plot these we get a
fairly high correlation especially when
we removed one outlier which you can see
here kind of pale so what I'm showing
here are for the six datasets they each
have three visualizations so there's 16
points with the average scores with the
average question score on one axis and
the average heuristic evaluation score
on the other axis so for example well
and so if participants tended to agree
that the design or blocking here that
the design was strong on the Aichi
condition and they also tended to answer
correctly in the QA condition and vice
versa so we found a strong correlation
well a moderately strong correlation
between the two so that was really
interesting however you will see that
the h ii was more reliable somewhat more
reliable than the QA and i'll talk about
that a little bit more so without the
owl our removed it was a less strong
correlation it was 0 point 38 in this
case so now the really interesting thing
is if you have outliers what does that
mean so we do have this outlier this is
in the jeopardy case so these are the
three jeopardy visualizations and here
are where they fall in the chart so you
can so what's really interesting here is
you can look at where do they fall with
the question score and where do they
fall with the heuristic evaluation score
and then you can look at and this is the
one where we had the big outlier and
this was 52 and this is one reason I've
been using this example it's a case
where people didn't give it as high of a
chi
they gave it actually it see ya that is
high of an H E score but it did well on
the questions so this would be a case
where as an instructor you might want to
take a closer look at it where maybe
your intuitions or your standard way of
assessing something needs to you me
didn't take another look at it and so
that's why this is this kind of an
interesting i think way to think about
doing assessments as an instructor is
that you're having these two ways of
measuring that are kind of correlated
most of the time but whether or not
maybe it's worth taking another look
furthermore and other cases where in
this case this is data about autos and
mileage they're all pretty close so
they're pretty close on the question
score one of them though has a higher
heuristic evaluation score number 21
which is the one on the top so they're
answering questions equally well like I
actually thought this one wouldn't do
very well because to me it has some poor
design components but it kind of maybe
got lucky on the questions so that's a
case where maybe you were going to want
to add more questions maybe we don't
have enough questions to tease that
apart so I'm going to talk about that
more in a minute and here's another
example these are this is another dog
breeds dataset and you can see here
where one of them is clearly doing worse
than the others this is what I expected
the stacked bar chart number 41 is doing
poorly on both dimensions but the other
two are doing pretty much the same on
the question score one is rated more
highly on the heuristic score so again
this gives you a lot to think about so
how might you use this tool yes
a difference that they're rated lower on
the heuristics like I did poorly
logistic valuation and difference will
like this outlier and also the second
one here 42 I'm wondering if it's you
know Houston valuation one of the
criticisms of it is finding false
positive so like you're finding problems
that don't exist in real people use the
interface so is that what those are
examples of in this case where you also
find the opposite that you get a high
average question score no you would have
to get a little bit you could find the
opposite we didn't find the opposite in
this data set but I think you could I
mean that's why I'm actually going to
run it again this semester in my class
so that's the thing is this is just one
run of this so I think we need a lot
more tries with it to see what happens
and let me talk about the reliability
assessment so we have two different
measures for each visualization but we
don't have any ground truth in the end
with this sort of thing there's no
ground truth is this how many questions
you get ride the ground truth or is a
heuristic evaluation or some other
judgment thing the ground truth that's
kind of to come to your question i don't
know i mean the arguments from the 90's
about this for about that as well right
there's not a true ranking for these
things no matter what we think right so
the ground truth is during usability
testing because they say it's real
people doing some real tasks and is it
true what they call discount clothing
closer to that yeah I know they said
some people said that but people didn't
necessarily agree with that and also
when you look at the literature on
information visualization tasks there's
a lot of classification so just the use
use in this manner is like one of you
know 12 classifications so it's
definitely not so that was my starting
point you see that when Manish said why
was that my assumption I started with
this utilitarian assumption but it's not
necessarily the case because I might not
have asked the right questions for one
thing so and actually
the h ii was surprisingly effective at
getting at what the question asks
answers found that's what surprised me
so much it was really quite these really
fast hese students did was really quite
well aligned with what the questioners
God so that's what impressed me so much
sure no I you know I've been looking
forward to hearing your thoughts on this
I think of a page and universities
ability testing although originally
Nielsen and others should say hey here's
a discount way of doing this I often
teach it as these are different things
that will find you different problems
and you want to be iterating between
them and this reduces your cost but
you'll find different things that 'he
will find you so you would never find a
usability test and vice versa yeah and
therefore like just that i would compare
them yeah and I have the spirit guides
on that that debate to the nineties well
actually I'm going to unhide my two
hidden slides here because because I had
a feeling but I didn't want to go there
if it didn't come up um okay I'm going
to jump to the use right now and a back
up to the reliability thing so yes that
was the debate all through the 90s and
then so the people that have revisited
it this howling said uh novick from this
usability inspection methods after 50
years of research and practice okay so
they were surveyed it said people are
still using these things and it remains
an open issue as to why usability
professionals in practice rely on single
perspective methods typically involving
users or experts but not both and then I
listed five research problems that
should be addressed a further research
question involves possible means of
combining multiple dimensions of
perspectives in a usable unified
usability inspection method so they said
it should be combined and zoo measuring
effective data visualizations said much
foundational research needs to be done
to improve the imagine it made from
information visualization including
closely correlates systematic heuristic
evaluation with user studies so I found
this after we did the work and I
reviewing literature two different
authors called for doing what we did so
I'd say that some thinkers are saying
this is probably a good idea that that
these people reviewing that back and
forth it's one or the other are saying
we ought to combine them so it is a new
way of thinking about it and I have to
tell you I've been wrapping my head
around it too and saying is it different
than doing them separately is it does it
have benefits i welcome you cogitating
on it and seeing if you think it gives
insight or not we have this reliability
assessment sort of going backwards it
looks like so we can't say which measure
is more accurate but we can say which is
more reliable in other words which
procedure generates a ranking that's
more consistent from one set of data to
another and so this is based in part on
the standard deviation of the mean
scores for each design when we did this
we found that the Aichi for our data was
more reliable than the question
answering there could be a lot of
reasons for that but it does suggest
that if we add more questions that might
improve it and one reason is that the
scores were binary either you got it
right or wrong for the question
answering and the HEA is graded but
there is a lot of research showing the
importance of finding the right task
this is true for info visits true for
information retrieval so I just think I
really felt like I was just picking some
questions and it was you know I did it
for a study it wasn't systematic it was
based on this yang it all stuff but you
know what if I'd had two more questions
so I think that is but it's much more
variable as well as what data did I put
put in the thing you know there's a lot
of variables so I think it needs more
study too but i think it's it's a new
take on the HP vs UT debate of the 90s
which has kind of stalled since 2007 but
the ideas instead of finding discrete
usability problems describing designs in
terms of continuous quality scales which
allows for spotting of outliers as maybe
which might be special and you know this
problem we have with
grading at scale where people feel if
they do something special it gets
ignored it gets punished right so we
want to avoid that problem it might
address students skepticism about either
method about the utilitarian asst of one
method or about the arbitrariness of the
other method and it might be more
accurate for ranking designs because
imagine if we have a huge database of
designs that have now been assessed and
you want to add a new one in we can
imagine this big scale we've developed
where there's two different measures
pulling off each other kind of like
ensemble learning and machine learning
now we know about Samba learning a
machine learning learning works best if
the ratings come from different
distributions are different underlying
sources and so that's kind of where I
think we have some interesting it's an
interesting idea which we don't
typically have in HCI question or
comment so that's I think it's kind of
neat here so it's a new take on peer
assessment i think for HCI and so we
have two different kinds of evidence and
that way that we have some idea
correlate but that come from different
places so so this study the design was
by the instructor the question was by
the instructor and the business buying
instructor and the h ii and the QA was
by the students like this this spring
the visualizations are going to be done
by the students as well as the HD in the
QA so now the students will be making
the visualizations and and my hope is
hope the summer to take it online and
have the questions made by the students
and maybe the data sets chosen by the
students although that might probably be
delayed a bit but eventually everything
done by students and make a huge data
bank of ranked assessed visualizations
high dimensional ones so that we can
really learn what works and what doesn't
about complicated static visualizations
to start with and so that we can
actually discover new design guidelines
I found even with the first study i did
with just the crowd workers
that my students came up with what I
felt were new design guidelines that I
would have been little less confident
about had they not scored so well that I
hadn't thought of for doing what they
did and so I think we'll find new biz
design guidelines from this approach the
advantage of this over what's been done
before is because I varying just the
data sets and the questions but the
method stays the same you will be able
to get a lot of mileage the because
you're still looking for extrema you're
still looking for correlations or
patterns whereas when you do a general
HCI class the goals are very different
in what the user interfaces are you know
so there's a more systematicity so I
think we have more of a chance to get
general principles about info booze out
of this potentially now it might be that
that the scores are not valid enough
that there's because of what the
students are doing that we won't be able
to trust the results so it might have to
put more checks and balances in or it
might just not be valid but it might
lead to a better understanding of info
bizim and and you know it's sort of a
clean cleaner model than just general
HCI Athey so let's revisit your what you
were asking at the beginning I want to
come back to the questions you were
holding this is a book you know one
thing this depends a lot of the
questions that you ask okay and Allah
could be backed up in that and so I'd
like to see those yeah so I think that
actually that's why doing it multiple
times with different questions will help
sort it out if you have a lot of
students you could have a lot of
different questions very time to the
visualizations right so if you say you
know give me the value of this
particular bar and that value is that a
label on that jar you know the
visualization has made it very easy
pants with us so why do with my students
is I didn't tell them the questions in
advance yeah so that makes it a harder
pendant so you can make rules about what
the valid questions are so they have to
you know have constraints on where they
are
bloom taxonomy and things like that too
yeah so I think that's a very valid
point yes coming back to the point you
are making earlier that this was about
assessment in classes you mean I think
correctly a point that II that unless
you have a simple and transparent rating
scheme like the more complex you get
this sort of the less trust that
students happiness so I'm wondering if
this sort of ensemble or sort of pca ish
assessment mechanism produces higher or
lower trust in the assessments that are
returned well I think it's a very very
simple it'll be very very simple it
would just be the average score that you
got right on I mean unless you made it
more complicated it's really just the
average scores people got right on a
visualization and the average HD that's
what were you doing right now yeah
feedback do I am I more willing to
accept the feedback if it's the expert
hey she be this is how people you know
empirically did on on your visualization
or this sort of mixed assessment that
somehow a weighted combination of them
and I'm wondering where you does the
simple one actually get absorbed more
readily well I'll tell you that when we
did this in my class the students well
so one of the students it ok so those of
us whose scores aren't very high with
just the question answering so you're
going to give us feedback aren't you on
how to improve it so i think that's
that's kind of a yes i am so in that
case they wanted to hear how to improve
their design so what I'm thinking here
is that students if you have like a plot
showing where there's fell with respect
to others if we had a way to show the
differences between their designs and
others that did better and worse on the
different questions you would show that
yes I don't know if it would be just
noticeable difference or a more
explanatory difference of you know how
this these different visualizations
handle the different parts of the data
set
I think it could be quite explanatory so
I think you could get beyond that it
would actually be almost a literal
description of how they were different
yeah see here and you're probably on
preaching to the choir ears that you
sort of coaching that way you're
pitching you may be the instructor you
extrinsic to the grading process in some
way which means that by complaining to
you i'm sort of i can have no effect on
how affect how well people could use the
visualization right so if not only
someone comes to me like look my
visualization is great isn't it i say
actually no it's not no it is right this
becomes a debate about my opinion versus
theirs and what you've done is you've
essentially sucked it out into some
external thing that's like well you know
people didn't do very well with it I can
help coach you but I can't change the
fact that this happen it's like it it
might have some impact on the
relationship you have with the student
as you're as you're doing this
assessment well I think you would news
for all assessments either so that's you
have multiple ways of doing things in
the class but actually I also think it
would be a really great way to assess
the heuristics as well or the guidelines
assessments to because these are more
that they're more like the Rubik's that
you you see in this standard peer
assessment and you could see which ones
lead to helpful feedback and which ones
don't as well to help explain to
students why their designs did well and
didn't do well as well because those are
in language you know and so you'll have
both this thing that shows people as we
know with usability tests when people
don't get things when people are lost in
design that's a very effective way to
communicate to people why the design is
poor and the same thing would happen you
know someone could answer a question
about your design that's very very
powerful then people want to understand
why not and the heuristics could the
guidelines could help explain why not as
well as the diffs so the students who
didn't do well on this thing they you
know they couldn't really question it
because people couldn't answer the
question that you know it's very
compelling but then they want the
explanation for why so
yes who do you think would learn more if
you're to do this twice someone who
doesn't do well the first time or
someone who does do all the first time
if they had to repeat kind of the
exercise again I don't know I don't know
but I do think it students do find it
compelling that they could repeat it
multiple times and do variations on
their design I don't know I don't know I
don't know do who do you think would do
better who do you think would help us I
should probably the negative feedback
told sleep with T more inclined to
really dig in and see what they did
wrong because long as a beat they fine
with me back helpful yeah yeah and I
know what I do in my class by the way is
I have people read the Dow at all paper
and then I asked him if they'd like to
do that i get x and there's a whole lot
of whole side thing about the pedagogy
oh my gosh it ooh boy shall I bought her
or just stay with this and not do the
other stuff power is yours questionnaire
or just an idea it seems like if I
wanted to solve the question part of the
issue here is that people are trying to
be graded on somewhat subjective task
and so if I wanted to discover our
objective ways to optimize data
visualization and I wanted to make a
class where students the way I
experiment teaching that is to actually
use physiological biomarkers of a
person's response to a data
visualization so a great example is
flywheel or equinox they have spin
classes now that we're data
visualization is key to driving
improvement in fitness and so then you
have a very specific physiologic Parker
as a function of time you have how many
watts insulin-producing in response to a
data visualization and then the students
have a very objective vector and then
you can even customize the visualization
by conditional on information about the
participants so someone in a retirement
community I'd actually had a vision
impairment in a way that you know a
teenager might not and so then you can
you can actually discover optimized for
answers based on very measurable
you could do that an eye tracking info
well so do you do want to measure for
the emotional response you want to
measure for if people feel that they're
gaining learning and it's just like you
yeah yeah we're not people to opt-in to
that of course you don't want people to
opt into that sort of thing of course
would be like yet how do you
automatically set up hunting and
measurable parameters and you create a
resolution that's a great riff on the
idea wait upon the evidence awesome ok
ok I'm pretty sure so you mentioned
potentially having students come up with
the questions in an online course for
the for the QA part could you talk a
little bit about how you think about
evaluating the quality of those
questions at scale so exactly at yeah
that's me i want to touch on to is the
whole crowd sourcing thing so we
definitely want to do some of the
techniques that are used for some the
crowd sourcing work where you have to
have a loop to see how well that's
working I mean that could be a whole
assignment in itself so there's a big
debate right now not big debate but
there's a debate in infamous about what
makes a good visualization so a lot of
people are talking about visualization
for insight and how do you measure that
so what we're doing here is just this
very narrow did can you extract a piece
of information and that's seen a super
narrow i give this at a very early
exercise in my class we have EDA
explore to our data analysis component
that's much richer and much more
difficult to to teach and I suddenly I
want to get a little bit too and so um I
way of how you get the questions that's
right so just formulating the questions
for exploratory data analysis is much is
like the hardest part of it in some
sense so for this you know we could have
the students study the unit on what is
that what have you classify the
different types of questions that are
appropriate for different sorts of
information needs within a visualization
and then you would have them positive
O's in absence of any data set and you
know that could be an assignment and of
itself and I could
being a whole unit and then that would
feed into this is an exercise but you
wouldn't just throw them out willy-nilly
it would have to be a kind of carefully
crafted kind of a thing but there's no
people do a lot of great work in the
crowd sourcing literature about how do
you have people propose things then have
others kind of give good feedback on
them and self reflective and so on yeah
I had just a comment about um you know
you mentioned inside I you know the most
important thing you know from a
visualization is inside to action right
what does this how do you differentiate
the signal from the noise especially in
this age of the data there's just a lot
of data being collected and really
understanding what are those key data
points that make sense that lead to
inside that will result in meaningful
action so I was wondering if you if you
had touched upon that and your media so
how do you get inside a big data so and
this is a very early exercise in the
course I have this whole sequence and
this is meant to be for the foundations
like learning to sketch in a art class
and so on so I don't know how to bring
that to this sort of pure assessment
kind of a level we are looking at in our
exploratory data analysis unit we want
to we are looking at a logging what
students do with their consent of course
and having them self reflect on the
process they went through of formulating
hypotheses exploring those hypotheses to
see if the data confirms or refute sit
and then making a display for
presentation of the results and seeing
what where do they get lost where did
they get confused what's the process
they go through but that's a much more
challenging problem and in fact since
since I am getting a little low on time
I think I might I will skip the little
the other topic that I've talked about
in the past and kind of jumped to that
later part which I can do here skip a
lot of stuff here and go to that topic
here
so I'm interested in this idea i'm
calling MOOCs in progress which is that
there are some things that we don't know
how to teach we don't really know how to
do very well an exploratory data
analysis are really getting insight from
friend data is one of those things and
so i talked about this thing so well and
so I haven't made a MOOC yet because I
guess I just don't feel like I have a
course I can just put online and have
all the auto grading and everything yet
and I don't know I'm chicken I trying to
slowly develop assignments like this one
reason I'm doing this is I want to put
it online I want to be able to put
assignments online that can have the
feedback and do it right and so one
thing I teach is this exploratory data
analysis unit and I don't know how to
put that online at scale and I don't
really know how to teach it I don't even
know how to do it that well most of us
learn from others and most people that
are good at it and learn from others and
get a lot of practice and see a lot of
examples and so on so I have this idea
of a MOOC in progress which is the
people who have put courses out often
have been teaching it for years and
really gotten it in great shape and but
rather than having to have a perfect
course out there where everyone expects
it to be perfect maybe starting with a
piece of a course and engaging some
experts or semi experts people who kind
of already familiar with the topic and
say hey everybody why don't you help me
develop this course and bear with it
bear with me let's all do it together we
all agree all this subject matter is
going to be public domain and we're
going to build it together so it's kind
of like learner sourcing but they're not
really beginner learners they're kind of
people with expertise and we'll start
out with some key material a core of it
and we're going to refine it together
and build it iteratively and explicitly
so that we might have some assignments
and the student will do some work and
will revise the assignments and will
study the changes in the work and will
develop more of a model of how it works
and develop the recommender or the auto
grader and this can be for exploratory
data analysis or debuggers or essay
tutors or any of these things where we
don't know either how it works at all or
we don't know how to automate it that
well and slowly grow the class at and
slowly add more people that are maybe
less expert until we have a course in a
kind of more forgiving way for the
instructor and so I think then what we
could do is with these logs we could ask
people okay do some exploratory data
analysis do it within these rules that
we're giving you give us feedback on how
we can improve this assignment give us
your logs let us analyze it and we'll
together make this really great
exploratory data analysis unit that we
can all that we can then release to kind
of any any taker so in kind of a safe
environment for the instructor which is
not something we talk about that often
but so that's that's kind of what I'm
thinking is that's how we maybe can
develop these things for these more
difficult topics where it doesn't have
to be perfect for anybody who might come
along and then we might be able to get
to these these harder topics so given
that you're don't have that much time so
my concluding thoughts is at least for
me this being learned a scale inspires
the imagination I was just so inspired
by the first MOOC that I heard about I
know it was the first one by the way no
Peter in our vegan sebastian's and I had
a screenshot but I didn't show it of
Peters little hand drawn multiple choice
question with the NLP you know syntax
tree that you needed to fill out I was
really inspired when I started to take
one and i saw the active learning where
there was multiple choice question after
10 minutes i'm like why am I not doing
that in my classes and I proceeded to do
it I proceeded to do active learning and
structured peer learning in my courses I
realized I should be teaching his way no
I wasn't hot this way but I should be I
learned from a MOOC how I should teach
in my classroom and inspired me to
experiment with things like this using
crowd workers to assess my students work
which I felt was was no for me anyway it
was an innovative way to teach and so
it's also made me start thinking and I
actually got some ideas for my
colleagues in computer science at
Berkeley about
teaching is coaching idea because
they've given up and some of them on
trying to grade the assignments which
you know this you know it's out there
how to do the assignments rather letting
people repeat them and then the exams
are what count to the grade and I
thought you know that's a really good
idea what if we just let people try
again and I can give them feedback and
you know give them points and it's about
the points and about doing it and not so
much about the grade and I'm coaching
them and that has really changed
everything and you know it's resulted in
teaching awards for me I mean it's it's
really makes teaching a lot more fun and
I think it makes learning a lot more fun
for the students and by thinking that
way it's changed what I have the
students actually do to prep they prep
for every class they do an activity
before the class and they do activities
in the class and you know they activity
no I very them a lot i read a lot of
pedagogy so it's not they always do this
or that they do a different thing before
different classes so and again these are
enabled because I can do stuff online so
I I really do think we are
revolutionising learning this plus
what's going on with the learning at
scale community and I hope that a lot of
you are inspired to go into this field I
know that for students education is very
exciting and I hope I heard that a lot
of you are thinking about it and I'm
really excited to see that a lot of the
best minds are thinking about education
going forward so thanks so much for your
attention cast another cases yeah
there's a nervousness movie say there's
a lot of variation based on winter
subset of data is shown in the
visualization which subset of data is
asked about and what you know which that
what combination is asked for in that
combination of the question of the data
but of course when we assess things now
are we looking at the hood I don't think
so so it's it would i would argue it's
better than what we currently do
whatever that is
Stu I wonderful interesting things your
announcement one where you did the
correlation between the two and focused
on the outlier is that what you want at
least in some techniques for asking
questions you think that so what this ha
pyar does and it looked like yeah buyer
would probably contributing you only go
both the problem is the question with
the outliner pods which should be able
domain and thing two forgot and the way
of measurement so I thought it was nice
away from on the scale a couple skills
we're way to pop out and out where that
you so your suggestion would be maybe
use that to decide what the additional
question should be for example version
bed and I reckon we never theory you how
do you interface out of work we try to
measure that but every once in a while
we discovered one top sellers even if
you got basically over here there's some
footage piece you got that's for the
post so why not one thing that happened
when I talk first of this exercises
student did a design that was really
different than anything I had seen and I
would have thought it was terrible it's
kind of like this red and green stop
light table sort of thing and I thought
it was awful and it came out the top in
scores and I was so glad I had done it
this way because I would have led them
wrong and maybe I'm just a bad judge and
I needed to see more things but it was
it was one reason I was so glad I had
this subjective approach and I now I
think I've seen more things like this
and I think I've learned the pattern
that it's a good design pattern and I
sit here and actually it did well in the
hero sticks too so maybe the students
are smarter than I am but you know you
could imagine things going the other way
so like you're saying it's the for me
that that table that scatter plot is the
key thing I think you're probably making
a more sophisticated point though about
this suggests we need to ask more
questions or maybe you're saying that's
saying the outlier allows you to get
specially written part two you come
aware of things that you didn't eat a
sport so scatter graphs and get into
talking life and numb I can't feel the
middle the right now the thing that
technique where you have people to give
lists of things are wrong generation I
thought to hear Martha more of your
thoughts about men yeah great let's take
Marty one with that
you